bonsoir bonsoir un des objectifs de la
ministre hier et c'était d'ailleurs dans
le titre du budget qu'elle a présentées
c'est de rendre la vie des canadiens
plus abordable est ce que les aînés y
trouvent leur compte
so lu ment pas pas dans le budget d'hier
et on a préféré le cabinet de la
ministre des aînés à ottawa nous ont
appelés à six heures en journée pour
nous demander ce que vaut connaître
notre réaction réseau fadoq et on ne
fait pas que c'était un budget où on
avait négligé les aimions les avais
oublié complètement donc les promesses
que monsieur trudeau a fait aux aînés
pendant la campagne électorale n'était
pas ne faisait pas partie du budget
quand on pense aux bonification du
supplément de revenu garanti
ce n'était pas dans le budget quand on
pense aussi à la création du crédit
d'impôt pour la prolongation carrière
s'était produit mais sur le supplément
de revenu garanti et quand même eu des
paiements spéciaux durant la pandémie et
dans la mise à jour qui a été présenté
au mois de décembre on a annoncé aussi
des compensations pour la perte du
revenu du supplément de revenu garanti
puisque des gens qui avaient touché des
prestations comme la prestation
canadienne d'urgence et la sécurité de
la vieillesse va monter aussi au mois de
juillet de 10 % pour les personnes de 75
ans et plus donc peut-être y avait rien
dans le budget mais il ya eu des choses
précédemment non il y avait des sources
les précédemment pour pas oublier qu'on
a souvent à cacher ça aussi à la
pandémie faut se rappeler que les
personnes qui reçoit de supplément de
revenu garanti vivent avec dix neuf
mille 500 $ par année à penser que le
loyer l'épicerie instituts et les
médicaments c'est beaucoup et c'est très
peu les gens mettent leurs mains dans
les poches à la fin du mois pour payer
le loyer et l'épicerie et laissez moi
vous dire qu'on a des retours des
commentaires nous disons que c'est très
difficile la précarité financière et les
bien réel chez elle chez les aînés vous
avez évoqué le crédit d'impôt pour
prolongation de carrière 5,6 au québec
le gouvernement du québec fait ça ça
fait partie aussi des engagements du
parti libéral le parti libéral l'a dit
en campagne le parti libéral fédéral est
ce qu est ce que ça fera une grande
différence pour les personnes de 65 ans
et plus qui hésite en ce moment à rester
sur le marché du travail ou à prendre
leur retraite selon vous
effectivement ça fait une grande
différence parce qu'il ya des gens qui
se disent pourquoi je resterai sur le
marché du travail ou retourner sur le
marché du travail
et pour pouvoir il ya un transfert de
connaissances qui se fait de ce côté là
non seulement cela c'est que les aînés
qui sont sur le marché du travail on en
connaît quand 68 70 qui disent bien
écoutez c'est une façon de socialiser
aussi de pouvoir de communiquer avec les
gens et quand on est occupé comme ça où
ça tient salle du ciel mais aussi les
hôpitaux ou des entreprises puissent
combler les journées donc quand est on
si plaisante mans avec la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre qui bat son plein et va
écouter ce soir était un avantage de
mettre dedans le budget
cette fois ci c'est ce crédit d'impôt là
pour aider donc pour stimuler aussi les
personnes à rester plus longtemps sur le
marché du travail c'est le veulent il ya
des gens qui ne sont plus sur le marché
du travail qui ont besoin de soutien
est-ce que vous avez vu quelque chose
pour les proches aidants dans le budget
n'ont actuellement pas et c'est une
autre promesse de monsieur trudeau et on
n'a absolument rien vu comme creeks
d'impôt remboursable et c'est un crédit
d'impôt remboursable de 1250 dollars qui
avait été convenu donc il n'y a
absolument rien de ce côté là ok non
seulement cela oui on avait aussi fait
part à la ministre
car à la fin du mois de janvier lors
d'un entretien
l'augmentation de 10% de la prestation
de la sécurité de la vieillesse vous
savez ce soit en branle pour les 75 ans
du mois de juillet exact mais on off oui
et on ne fait pas des besoins vitaux du
côté des 65-74 ans qui eux il y en a
plusieurs qui n'ont pas de deux fonds de
pensions indexées ou qui n'ont pas
finalement de deux fondations donc ça
aurait été un avantage de médecins de
l'est va donc encore là on a voulu
maintenir le cap on
on s'est assuré de l'offrir seulement
aux aînés de 75 ans est ce que vous vous
réjouissez un retour des soins dentaires
gratuits par exemple pour les aînés de
65 ans et plus
avec les revenus de ménages en bas de 90
mille dollars à partir de 2023 il ya un
crédit aussi pour la rénovation de
propriétés
multigénérationnel savez le réseau fadoq
accueille favorablement ces bons coups
là effectivement vous savez que le
programme national de soins dentaires
pour les pour les personnes aînées pour
les personnes avec un handicap entrera
en vigueur seulement qu'en 2023 donc ça
a été des questions que nous avons
posées au cabinet hier qu'est ce que ça
va comporter exactement est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que ça va me vois nulle elle
exactement est ce que c'est un rendez
vous annuel pour l'hygiène dentaire est
ce que les obturations est ce que les
personnes qui nécessitent une prothèse
dentaire est ce que ce sera couvert on
ne pouvait répondre à aucune de ces
questions on doit nous revenir de ce
prix là c'est un peu la mode les deux
derniers budgets on nous annonçait les
détails sont à venir faites vous encore
en vie avec les détails donc je présume
qu'on aura plus de détails aussi du côté
des soins dentaires mme adam goodman
madame tassé goodman merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci bien